le nouveau recteur de l'académie de la
réunion velayudam marimoutou s'est rendu
au musée léon dierx et à l'artothèque
afin de découvrir les équipements
culturels du département en présence de
béatrice sigismeau vice présidente élue
à la culture
le recteur et la conseillère
départementale ont rappelé l'importance
pour la jeunesse réunionnaise d'être
sensibilisés au patrimoine culturel de
notre île décorer les équipements
culturels la réunion ça fait partie
aussi de l'argent des infrastructures
pour l'éducation les équipements
sociales sont extrêmement importants
puisque ils permettent justement de
donner à aux enfants ou aux étudiants
tout le socle de comprendre les oeuvres
pour comprendre l'intime pour comprendre
comment se construit une oeuvre dans
toute la créativité c'est très important
parce que il ya quand même un
partenariat qui est mise en place avec
le rectorat avec pour nos enfants pour
tous les publics et le public jeune
aussi leur faire connaître les musées
leur faire découvrir l'art et ya comme
ça des des projets et des talents qui
peuvent naître à travers notre jeunesse
outre les projets menés en commun entre
l'éducation nationale le département ce
sont des milliers de jeunes qui chaque
année grâce aux aides départementales
découvre les équipements culturels de la
collectivité